learn message today
okay just in case because it hasn't
updated with
the um footage just yet so i think we've
done like an intro
says live according to him
no it still says oh we've got an ad i
think we're in
okay
should we reintro this yeah all right
we'll give it a second we'll we're just
waiting for more people to get in here
so everyone can see this awesome menu
that we're showing off right now
now we're in now we're in hell yeah
anyway hi everyone
uh do you want me to do it all right i'm
lucy joined by jake uh you might have
already heard this introduction uh
however youtube decided not to update
and was just keep showing me the
thumbnail and didn't actually play the
stream so
if you've already heard this intro so
i'm lucy this is jake
we're playing assassin's creed so as i
said before too uh we
are going to start a new game we're
going to play a little bit at the
beginning and then we'll load into a
later save
uh to check out england because as it
turns out it takes a bit of time to get
to england i think it took me like
three or four hours i think it took you
something similar dude tell me it took
me closer to five
and i thought that i was just mainlining
everything but
i am one of those people that i just i
just kind of keep looking and you know
something shiny on the horizon so
you know took me a little bit a little
bit longer
all right you're going through all your
what are you going to play on just
playing on
i played on yeah i played on default
everything i kind of thought about maybe
doing hard but
i was going to say if i die our audience
is just going to be like
if i die already it's just like this guy
sucks this guy sucks this guy sucks but
i can't see chat so
don't worry i'm so i'm on chat um
jen says
i guess well i mean that's i don't know
so
i'm actually british i know you can't
actually tell because
all over the sometimes um it's very
nice and strange for me to be playing an
assassin's creed game based on something
that we actually learned about in
history
oh yeah yeah not like the american
revolution
oh i was so lost
i was very very lost i'm ashamed to say
uh however having lived in america for a
couple years i do definitely and having
watched hamilton
i will adjust that once i loaded the
game i just hit my mic too obnoxiously
so the setup we have here i have to
change that in game so once this
cutscene is done i will get on that i
can't skip the cutscene either also this
is on a series at
series x that was interesting so it
looks real nice
it does so i can talk to my experience
um having played on the one x
which i didn't expect there to be that
much of a jump between them but i mean
actually well now hang on someone says
santos lara says can't hear the game
can't hear the game i did pause it
oh so maybe that's probably why um the
difference between series x and
one x is quite remarkable um i honestly
didn't expect the jump to be that high
but in terms of loading times um
i can already see that you are facing
little to none whereas
me playing on one x is like over a
minute
just to load into it here's a tube for
you
but yeah so this is the very beginning
of the game
jd king in the chat is obsessed with
rain
all right
comedy
[Music]
does the does it sound a little better
in chat hopefully people do hear the
audio
yeah chat let us know about the audio
hey brandon hernandez uh if you have any
questions about the game we're obviously
not going to delve into spoiler
territory
um because the game isn't even out yet
and that would be a real jerk move
um we can talk about we're not going to
yeah we're not going to talk in a big
heavy story spoilers or anything like
that but if you have any questions about
combat
getting around you know how it feels
compared to other assassin's creed games
how it feels compared to
games like ghost of tsushima we can
definitely
speak to that and if there's anything
that you want us to go do or try and
check out
oh nick anderson says other subtitles
and chris beaumont says it's still a
little
there are subtitles i will turn on
subtitles that's probably a good idea
since
we're probably gonna talk over some of
this and i will turn it down a little
bit more
the joys of trying to do this at home is
that i don't have a mixer i can't
individually control the audio
unfortunately
but we're gonna make this work
smidge too loud hazy jace is
going between 25 and 50 master game
volume
25 and 50 all right i can lower it a
little bit more
oopsies about 40.
and then
while you're figuring that um it's a
gameplay karachi arcade says can you one
hit assassinate
bosses um i don't know actually
so there is an upgrade that you can
unlock
that um gives you a kind of quick time
event
so usually when you try and hit rb to
assassinate on a boss
obviously you can't really do that you
can do a critical strike to take off a
bunch of their health but you can't one
hit them like that
but there is an unlock and i don't want
to
like absolutely confirm or deny that it
does one hit them
but it does give you a quick time event
that takes either way more damage off or
does one hit them so
there are options for it but i also
think it's dependent on bosses
i i think if it's like a random boss you
find you encounter in the world
probably that would work but if it's
gonna be you know a boss that's way over
over your level or maybe even a story
related boss
getting emotional just thinking about it
you're probably not going to be able to
one hit kill those
okay i see all these settings for oh
unless it's here oh subtitle display oh
my gosh i'm an idiot
all right there we go that should fix it
hopefully
[Applause]
[Music]
uh and thank you uh karachi arcade
there it is
[Music]
ah chris beaumont all caps subtitles
but it's not always in the sound sound
panel like i was looking at interface
because that's where i'd expect it to be
sometimes sometimes it's in um oh he
retracted that message
okay so if you're just joining us
because we just got an influx of people
just there
uh this is the very beginning of the
game your subtitles on please feel free
to ask us any questions on the chat i'm
also
[Music]
hi freddie mercury how are you doing
who's back from the dead i thought we
lost you
what am i playing come on what are you
doing
uh and hazy jason's volume mixing sounds
perfect cool
eric e 28 has there been a massive
change in the graphics so jake do you
want to speak
to because you've played it on two
different platforms well within the xbox
ecosystem i suppose
yeah so i played it on actually i played
it on the xbox one
s earlier today not the series that's
the one s
and it looked rough resolutions looked
pretty bad
things in the distance looked incredibly
muddy uh
and there's just a lot of detail missing
this looks much better
obviously the one s the one
s not the series s and then
and then i played and then i'm playing
on the series x now which looks
significantly better and lucy you played
a little bit on the
one x yes um i've got my
one x live masterson all right
live so i know like
it's so weird it's just saying the names
of all the
xbox is in such like quick succession
like that it's really like i just
my brain is double checking to make sure
that i get it right every time
oh no i gotta turn off notifications
so playing on one x um
and especially looking at the footage
that jake got on
um series x the one x there was quite a
lot of screen tearing
um and also the the footage does look
much dark um i don't know if it's just
because the lighting has been
fascinating
but the the i think the main gripe for
me
in terms of playing one x um
you can see behind me cleared space
for my series x which i know is on a
fedex truck somewhere
um the biggest gripe for me is certainly
the loading times
i think uh having been playing on a ps5
for a couple weeks i've definitely
become spoiled
uh when it comes to loading times and
the 1x version of assassin's creed
valhalla
if you so you can this is not a spoiler
you know that you begin in norway and
the vast majority of the game takes
place in england but going over from
norway to england took
me uh one minute seconds
and on the series x it took 17.
that's the big um
kind of difference that you're looking
at
[Music]
so yeah that's that's the big graphical
difference screen tearing
i've noticed a few bugs here and there
but obviously
um
yeah i had some weird when i first
played it once again this was like even
for the day one
patch um but i had some weird glitches
like in particular
you know the character who wants to
drink with you at in the tutorial
she was like super far away from that
area and i talked to her and all of a
sudden we just slingshot it into that
area and started drinking and i was like
all right
i guess i guess we're here now
it's um
[Music]
we should ask chat to get ahead of it
should we play as male 8 or female avoir
or should we do
like animus decides which basically
switches us between the two
what do you mean so i i picked female
able what does it what do you mean it
switches
yeah there's three options i don't think
it's randomly i think it just like
whichever
story you do or whichever like i forget
what they're called arc you do
it'll just assign the a4 that maybe they
think makes more sense the curtains are
raised
that's really cool
the england map seems a little bit
smaller than odyssey actually it seems
quite a bit smaller than odyssey
but this also has norway too which you
can explore which in itself seems pretty
big
um not not like massive though yeah
norway
is definitely i would say way more
manageable
it's like white orchard and witcher 3
yes i was just thinking
it is very much like the white water and
then
england is much bigger than i thought it
would be it's also more
dense so actually i guess we can talk
about this um i i'm assuming this is why
they've done it so
if you think back to assassin's creed
odyssey and assassin's creed
origins like it did get some flag both
of those games too big and
these things these points of interest
can just kind of appear on your map but
they don't go
and so that's what really it is
very similar to the picture i guess like
all the question marks you just kind of
like
clear them and see what they are because
you have no idea
um so
that's one way of kind of
you did bring up like the world events
and stuff which i actually do appreciate
quite a bit in this game because they're
very
short and manageable they're not these
big long
winding side quests which to be fair i
do love but it's nice to just like
meet a character and they have a dilemma
that you can solve in two different ways
and you just decide and see the
ramifications of it right away it's
pretty cool
yeah i mean i think the one thing that
i'm maybe
i'm not struggling with is the wrong
word uh
in terms of having decide stuff not
necessarily the quest log is that you
have a lot of people in your settlement
and they have little
[Music]
um kind of tent where you take kills and
you can get
you know you you kill legendary animals
and give them to them and they'll
taxidermy them
um but then they kind of like have
little quest lines and they have one
backstory and that's not really logged
anywhere
i just like accidentally did that
because i'd killed a legendary animal
and then
oh so someone says my my mic is lower
than game audio
your mic is lower than game audio uh
according to a couple people
so i don't know i'll i'll speak louder
while you well they can figure that one
out
um so yeah there's like side quest stuff
with
other characters that you can't really
track
and like you just kind of fall into
their quest lines a bit randomly so i
wanted to
you know turn in something and i ended
up going on a 10 minute long
little side mission uh this morning
so it's a bit it's a bit strange
hopefully that's better hopefully that's
better
please continue to let us know still
this is the very
very opening of the game i'm hoping like
once we get out of the cutscenes too it
should sound a little better because it
won't be like constant
talking in in sound effects and
crunching over wolves biting
children yep
but the whisper says why are they
talking over the cutscene because we're
answering people's questions we've got
the subtitles on if you do
want to follow the story this has just
been the very beginning of the game
uh let me know if this mic sounds a bit
better
[Music]
ah so boss gaurus i hope i said that
right said hope the ai will get massive
upgrade slash be smarter on next gen
current gen ai is very disappointing
it's the most important aspect of the
video game
um well if if he's talking about or if
they're talking about just in general
i agree i hope ai gets better as for
assassin's creed i don't think there's a
difference between ai across platforms
yeah i i would say that you know ai not
necessarily
being that great in this one just yet
which is i mean honestly i kind of
like it because sometimes you just
especially in a big huge open world game
sometimes you just kind of want to knock
out a few side quests and you kind of
rely on that pretty stupid ai
that just kind of feels quite nice how
does how does chat feel which should we
do female
male or let the animus choose yeah
sorry uh james the ick king says
uh james it the king 29 says sorry
but ival should have been killed by that
wolf when she was bitten
i am going to there we go get rid of
that
person um
uh hurricane yes it is a review copy uh
let us know if you want to play it as
female or male ivor for the rest of this
or
let so just to propose something to chat
the other save i have is female ivor so
we could do mail for this opening and
then when i load into the london save we
can
or not the london save the england saved
we can do female
but you can also just change it on the
fly so like i could just pick one and we
could change at some point i don't know
if the game has to reload if you change
looks i haven't done it
uh a lot of people in the chat say male
1 and animus so
let's go mail yeah um the hurricane yes
this is a review copy we had it early
um kembla kem bilge says play both and
we can compare the voice acting
all right
how long have you been chasing me i
haven't actually even
played any of my life
okay
you remember this ah
your father's ass the weapon of a coward
a scorn snake
ah few things would please me more than
to kill
uh unfortunately we're not a retailer i
think you're thinking of game
stop sorry uh we don't
we don't sell the games we just talk
about them
uh and yeah the game is out tomorrow it
is a series x
slash s launch title um
yeah okay so jamie the
king 29 26's i think they focus too much
on the vikings
not the assassinations but the game is
still good in my opinion what do you
think jake cause like
i know you're a long-time fan of
assassins as well do you think that the
franchise has definitely skewed more
towards the action
compared to the i don't know it's
stealth origins
yeah i don't know i've had such an
interesting relationship with the
assassin's creed series like the only
one i finished is assassin's creed 3
which everyone says is the worst but
i've played them all
uh and like to be honest i've never been
a huge fan until
i don't even know i'd say i'm a huge fan
now but i've never been paid a lot of
attention to the assassin's creed games
until origins and odyssey
in this game i've really enjoyed the new
trilogy but i think that is because
i'm obsessed with the witcher 3 and
there's a lot of clear inspiration from
the witcher 3.
uh that being said though i love a good
stealth game and
i do not do stealth in this game at all
because it just seems weird for a viking
to be like
stealthing into a camp like i've got two
axes i want to run in and just
hit people with axes so i totally get
that
criticism that people would have uh
there are still a bunch of
assassinations you can do
as you progress i think like odyssey had
it too where they had that whole web of
characters that you can assassinate if
you'd like and
and that stuff is still there that stuff
seems pretty cool i've done a couple of
them
but once again i just kicked open the
front door and was like i'm gonna kill
you now and
fought them yeah i i in the exact same
frame of mind because i mean actually as
well i just been replaying some of ghost
of tsushima
and i feel like that's my outlet for
being
a stealthy ghost you know like just
assassinating and taking people out
quietly
um but with valhalla i agree like it
doesn't make sense to be this
viking and just sneaking around in the
dark it makes so much more sense just to
go in like
i really love doing raids um i think he
said
like when we go to england we'll do some
raids which are really fun and they kind
of remind me of
um not to the same degree
as uh the what were the big battles in
shadow of war you know when you take on
uh strongholds okay
we take on strongholds and you kind of
take your army with you and you attack
a stronghold it just kind of feels like
that but you don't assign people roles
like you did in shadow of war
it's you know like you blow your horn
you run up the bank
and you've got your axe swinging you
just take out dudes it feels really good
um but and you can i guess like
go back and become anonymous and then
quickly find the stuff that you need to
end the raid but it's like
it's not fun to do it that way yeah so
it's very strange that assassin's creed
is like not a stealth game anymore
like yeah they did bring back
instant what are we doing here are we
going to climb up there we go
there you go uh they did bring back
those instant assassinations though
actually maybe they did it with odysseus
it's an unlockables
but yeah there is not me yeah
there is a way to do those and some of
the tougher enemies you have to like
time it too which i think
is yeah kind of cool rather than just
seeing the animation it's like
press rb at the right time yeah
um i was doing that in a side mission
last night and it was the first one i'd
ever done i just
oh yeah you also don't have leap of
faith unlocked at the very beginning
yeah that's a strange one
um i accidentally like completely biffed
the jump because i just assumed that i
could leap a faith off and look at that
what a nice view we got here
what a nice view
um so yeah a lot of questions in the
chat about
uh differences between hdmi 2.0 and hdmi
2.1
uh i mean it comes down to like hdmi 2.1
can do 120 hertz or 120 frames
at 4k um i am not playing on 4k and i'm
not playing 120 hertz i don't even think
this game supports 120 hertz
but yeah you have to have a expensive tv
um
that has hdmi 2.1 and you'll get the
benefit of 120 frames and 4k
that being said though i think you can
still do 120 frames
on like 1080p if you have a monitor or
something like that because i was doing
some gears like that
uh sanel pereira asks do you think the
facial animation is bad in valhalla
uh it's not great but it's not bad
i find it yeah i think it's it's
definitely
getting there um there are bits where
you know i've been talking to
a character in my camp and they are like
the wink at you or something it's still
not
as it's obviously not
like a one-to-one face already like an
actual person's face or anything but it
is much better than it was
um uh brandon hernandez asks when is the
extra life charity stream going to be
the 20th right is when it starts 20th so
not long to go all kind of um we've all
been working quite hard on next-gen
stuff so
uh extra life can go at any point during
november
so we we're not using the same weekend
that we normally do we kind of pushed it
to the 20th to give everyone
a little bit of a break and get
reinvigorated again for extra life
um so that'll be on the 20th keep an eye
on the site and on twitter and
everything
um details but we are planning that at
the moment it's gonna be
a good time and hopefully we'll raise a
lot of money for the kids
i notice your camera feed is getting a
little a little glitchy i don't know if
i can fix that though i think it might
just be google hangouts
being uh google hangouts doesn't like
my um camera i do know that for free
so let me try we can we can hear you
well though
i i think as long as we can hear you
oh wait i think we're good yeah okay
there we go
uh louis griffin in your opinion is it
worth upgrading from a 1x to a series x
is it a significant difference
uh i went from a 1x to a series x
uh i
i guess it depends like do you have a 4k
tv that can do
hdmi 2.1 because if you're still on a
1080p tv probably not
um the big difference you're gonna
notice right now is that loading times
are much faster
and games will run smoothly
but the big thing are the loading times
and since you can play pretty much all
these
games on your ex right now uh i would
say you're probably fine to wait
a little bit uh especially if you
weren't able to pre-order one like i
wouldn't fret it
i would just you know wait until you'd
save up a bit more money or
maybe wait for halo or a game that you
really want to see on it that being said
though if you're really excited for
assassin's creed and you want it to be
like
the best it can be short of getting a pc
then i mean
by all means it might be worth upgrading
but like it's not like previous console
generations where you're going to be
missing out on games
you'll just spend more time in loading
screens
more time to doom scroll yeah
uh daniel moreno hi daniel uh hey guys
are there any noticeable improvements to
photo mode in valhalla
trying to give it a whirl we can
i don't know if there are noticeable
improvements
i think it's pretty much the same
because i didn't use a lot of it
um yeah i didn't really use a lot of it
when i was playing
odyssey either daniel moreno takes some
great photos though especially
like ubisoft games so yeah like depth of
field exposure contrast temperature tint
saturation noise vignetting bloom fog oh
you can add fog
uh ivan is ac valhalla ps5 version good
i don't know
i haven't got it on that platform um
jake who on the team has it on the
playstation
jean-luc is playing on ps4 um
and he says it doesn't look that great
he's playing on pro
yeah so i don't think the ps5
um upgrade had been out yet but the xbox
one came out
first um so we were able to look at it
on xbox series yeah kevin paymar says
ps5 plays ps4 games well check out ghost
of sushima
yeah so ghost is a really good example
of a game that has been
um like a ps4 game that has then been
optimized
for playstation 5. so they had a patch
loading times are much better um
i don't know but it all depends it's a
game by game case by case
basis so assassin's creed valhalla is
gonna get a ps5 update that actually
hopefully should be live today
well because the ps4 ps5 launches a few
days later maybe the patch isn't out
just yet i can't
confirm like i said i'm not playing it
on that platform um
but it should it should be more
optimized for that
uh corral yes we can select the gender
of your protagonist
we did earlier playing as male um just
in this section at the beginning when
we're in norway
we'll be playing as female ivor when we
go uh
to england oh i can't see something
make it work i was gonna say kiss the
books are slippery yeah
i should have this on a separate feed
but uh all right fine
the the the janky setup
um eric says do you prefer the series x
over the ps5 there'll be a lot of
questions
yeah and we can't really answer them
right because you've got a ps5 but don't
have a series x i have a series x but i
don't have a ps5
yeah so um
nicholas mattingly do the weapons break
no they don't uh i mean
shields on enemies break like you can
break shields but your stuff does not
break
yeah as you can see i've done a great
job at stealthing my way through this
area
is it native 4k what frame rate and are
there any options for performance
4k60 i don't think there are any
performance options in series
x let's take a look um alfonzo
my cam quality i can't do anything about
it that is actually a google
uh hangout issue because my camera
quality is banging
but google doesn't like it yeah i'm
sorry as far as i can tell i don't think
there's any options which is
a trend that we're kind of noticing with
the series x games now
is that like most of these games that
have been released
cross-generationally can run 4k 60. so
there's not really much of a point this
isn't 4k i'm not playing it at 4k
right now because i don't want to do
that to my internet
um how do i get in here i think i gotta
climb
yeah you gotta climb that one uh sound
painters
i don't know i don't know uh silas says
do does iphone have the assassin's blade
not yet but yeah yes you do get it
eventually
and that kind of like goes off the point
i was saying about how or how the
stealth stuff because ivor even is like
i don't want to put it
i don't want to hide it i want to put it
so my enemies can see it
smells like batman jumping on these
little
gargoyle things
uh cinel says we need more blood in this
game uh i think there is an action there
is actually an option
for to have blood and stuff turned on i
think it's on by default right
yeah it should be on blood and gore
there's like a blood gore nudity
and i think even a language setting like
as in a cursing setting that you can
turn on and off uh captain mouse hey
guys
how's the comeback compared to ghost of
scishow
i think i prefer ghost suzushima more it
feels a little bit more fluid and like a
little more deadly
i think than this it's not as dependent
on the
jrpgness that this is
but i don't know how do you feel lucy i
prefer ghost i think ghost
nails i don't know it's way more and i
would spare your life
shut your hole how do i describe it like
if we're gonna use something like
a bloodborne or a dark souls as being
like
precision matters i think ghost of
tsushima
does a really good job of making sure
like your
your hits count you get feedback on
those hits
you don't just feel like you're swinging
and like hopefully that you're gonna
miss
you're gonna hit something like it does
actually feel like your hits count
in i don't know
it's very strange in valhalla like when
you play it you'll kind of see that like
the waiting of the character the waiting
on eyeball feels a bit strange and
sometimes
you can swing your blade and or your axe
and it can just go through like
two or three um enemies and just doesn't
feel
i'm loath to use the word realistic but
um i don't know it doesn't feel as
um as good as it
as i want it to be if i'm if i feel like
i'm being spoiled by
dark souls where precision really
matters there's your blood
as your blood uh kevin how did you buy
the series x
uh i pre-ordered mine from the microsoft
store
uh i bought it from a friend because i
couldn't the pre-orders were
were gone so shout out to chris pereira
on our team who's sending me one of his
extras
chris farrell
um this series x though is provided by
xbox
that was a very good call out very good
read
this series x42 this series x uh this is
yeah one of our review units that we
consent
uh oh this is a good question mayan 67
what do you think will be the first next
gen game which is
more than a current gen game with higher
fps and resolution
i don't know i mean like the easy answer
i feel like is demon souls right because
that one is only going to be for ps5 and
that is using like the 3d audio at least
supposedly it's going to be using 3d
audio and like
but i don't think that's probably the
answer you're looking for since it is a
remake
um how much did your friend charge you i
think you just charged him
how much it cost um yeah
i would say i'm trying to think because
it's it's highly possible that there's
going to be question
uh games that are made for both jen for
a while
like we know for example that there's a
new god of war coming but we don't know
if that's going to be just for ps5 or
it's going to be in ps4 as well
um miles morales is
on both it's in terms of xbox like xbox
are talking about you know this
commitment to everyone can play because
it's the xbox family and that's like
the series x and the series are just
more powerful
xboxes so in terms of a game that's
going to be truly next-gen
maybe i don't even think we've seen it
yet i think it's way too early to tell
um i mean the medium right that game is
supposed to be only
next-gen consoles in pc or like the
series x like maybe we'll expect
something from that but i
like if you're hoping if you're
expecting like big aaa i don't know if
that would count since it is a
smaller studio even though they do make
great games
xbox series x or the ps5 please answer
me
from unboxing goods we kind of already
did talk about it jake's got a series x
and i have a ps5 but neither one of us
have both
just yet kevin uh was it easy to
pre-order
for me i was just very lucky being on
amazon at the right time
and on the microsoft store at the right
time your mileage may vary depends on
the country you live in so
i don't know if i can help you out more
there and hopefully there'll be more
stock in soon
in soon i like was on twitter right when
they restock target
for ps5 someone just tweeted it and i
just followed the link and got it no
problem at all
series x though could not get i woke up
the day the pre-orders went live i had
every
freaking retailer's website open and
ready to order could not get it
could not get it at all um i
i was i mean we accidentally filmed uh
we were having a planning meeting about
your next
weekly show on gamesworld series and
series s and ps5
please watch every friday um but we were
having a planning meeting
and that was when the playstation 5
pre-orders went live so we accidentally
caught us all on camera like trying to
get it and it's just all
of us just being super stressed because
none of the retail stuff is working
um and like stuff would crash i was
trying to get best buy it would go to my
um it would go to the cart but i
couldn't check out and then eventually
walmart worked
and then with xbox it was just super
super slow i used the microsoft store
because i couldn't even get in on any of
the other retailers
even though i'd had all the browser web
pages open i'd been following wario64 on
twitter to get the direct links and just
none of it worked
the microsoft store eventually worked
but it was super super soft
so it was difficult and i just don't
think there's any especially in these
strange and unusual times i don't think
anyone could have
you know anticipated the demand for new
consoles and
retailers just kind of struggled
grab yours
once once and you know this god of war
sequel is weird
like boating between places i think is
is really cool i don't know why it's
just like it's very relaxing and
it looks pretty and nice it's one of my
favorite things that they had in uh
ac for black flag as you know the the
songs
and i don't i can't remember if having
stories was in other ones but
you know kratos telling atreya's stories
was such a really nice part of god of
war and the way that you know
if you decided to get off the boat and
like you'd interrupt the story then
you'd get back on and trace would go
okay where were you like can you finish
the story
and i like that assassin's creed has
these stories and these tales that they
tell on the boat as well
um it's really nice because also
i just love i love learning about norse
mythology i keep meeting to read the
neil gaiman book but
um god of war really stirred
an interest in that
hi harry thank you very much
all geared von evereck where is he
sadly not all good i think another thing
i love most about all gear is how much
he looks like dave beckham
oh yeah he was such a good character too
that whole psc was so good
i mean both the dlcs are good but that
one the story just hit
different
i'm excited for the dlc in this game too
like
it seems like i don't know if i'll end
up playing it because usually it's tough
to go back
and play that kind of stuff but i know
odyssey had some like
good-sized dlc with some really
interesting locations but i think they
said you'll be able to go to ireland i
think and i'm like oh that sounds pretty
cool
yeah cause i don't really know that much
about
but i know that so jordan remain who
reviewed uh
this for us and he's a big assassin's
creed fan and he was saying that um
with assassin's creed odyssey obviously
the game itself is like
85 hours and then the atlantis dlc
was basically like another full-length
game you said it was like 40 something
hours to complete that so
i am not worried about content
in this game i think there's gonna be a
lot more of it
uh yes your crewmates can sing
uh i don't think i can do it right now
in the tutorial but yeah when you're
just like exploring randomly you can
have them sing or tell stories too
are there any great easter eggs in this
game there's a question from tri-lands
there's a lot yeah apparently there's a
lot that might be spoilery
um yeah i think we should be be careful
about
that i know in jordan's review he said
assassin's creed fans will probably be
very happy
with some of the references in like
loose ends that get tied up and whatnot
which as someone who's only finished
assassin's creed 3 that [ __ ] means
nothing to me i'm just like yeah i want
to be a viking
like i i remember i think the last time
i got really excited about
assassin's creed easter eggs and stuff
was in
four when you kind of go to the modern
day abstergo stuff and you can look
in um you can kind of sneak through all
their files and read emails and they had
like
references to watch dogs and everything
in there but
i i don't know i kind of i'm at the
point now
that i i'm not interested in the modern
day stuff i like the fact that there's
this mythology this like overarching
mythology that everything connects but
i'm not personally on the hunt for it if
i see something that's a nice little
easter egg i do like it there has been i
will say because it's very early on
um there was a monty python reference
that i caught
that's the stuff that i'm looking for
there's a super cool copic 19 reference
oh yeah mr coven reference like one of
the emails you could read is it it like
benches it and i was like this is this
is 2020. this is the world we're living
in
this is how long we've been dealing with
this that game developers have been
working on a game for five years we're
like yeah we should add this in
um kevin thanks for watching
we're not we're not a retailer i think
you still think we're gamestop
but thank you for the very good
questions about ordering consoles and i
hope you get one
um because we could all use some more
good news
and you know playing fun games um
so you are going to be finishing it on
series x once you get your series x so
just switch over to that
yeah except i think i'm gonna absolutely
do myself in
because i'm gonna be dual wielding
assassin's creed on xbox
and then demon souls on playstation um
[Music]
so i mean i kind of i remember doing
that with uh horizon zero dawn and
zelda breath of the wild like two very
bow-based
games uh two different types of
traversal um
so i remember doing that too i played
through
horizon very fast because i wanted to
get to zelda but i had to like finish it
for coverage pre
reasons both great games but i just
remember
everyone talking about breath of the
wild and i was like oh i can't wait to
get into this
okay let's jump right in uh a couple of
people on the chat are asking could you
do limited hud
i can i can try to
if i've learned this stream it's that
i'm terrible with menus
uh oh wait yeah they're asking about
graphics and stuff
so we are playing on xbox series x but
we're not streaming in 4k
um so that's you know this is
series x running 1080p
i see that's good i just turned off a
couple things
yeah that's probably not good maybe
maybe turn off the quest log yeah i'm
gonna turn off the quest log too
uh people in the chat are also kind of
trying to figure out what the next
assassin's creed game will be
um or what we what we would like to see
from the next assassin's creed game
okay get rid of this tutorial here uh i
mean everyone says this but i would love
japan
i would love like something a little bit
more modern like uh like i think during
like
being in russia during like the russian
revolution would be
like freaking badass that'd be really
cool because like some of the
some of the stories there of like not
mister the things that happened
during that are crazy like like rebels
blowing up like
cars that uh or carriages that like
like the czars are in and what it's it's
wild it'd be so cool
yeah a lot of people are also calling
for japan um
i would definitely still love feudal
japan i know we had it
uh in ghost of sushima but i love that
region
the culture is super interesting and i
would love to just
wield a katana and go around i would
love to do that
i think he was approaching
i don't know like we kind of had
egyptian you've got to see some roman
stuff in there but i would love
you know like full-on not as in
renaissance rome but as in like the
roman empire that would be cool
yeah world war one actually
how does the xbox run have there been
any issues
uh i mean it's run great other than some
bugs that i've encountered in this game
that hopefully you won't even experience
when
you get your hands on it but it runs
pretty solidly
uh i haven't noticed much frame rate dip
i have noticed some which you also said
with the 1x but i have noticed a little
bit of screen tearing here in there
um so screen tearing i've noticed quite
quite a lot
on the one x version yeah i wonder part
of me is wondering if maybe it's
something
i did with my capture card because
they're both using the same capture card
but i don't think so
yeah but no i mean actually i was
playing it like straight into my tv and
i was getting
oh yeah it might just be the game
um oh i did see a good question if you
scroll back to it
oh china china would be cool too i know
they had the assassin's creed chronicles
of china
i think they did one with russia too
they did yeah
uh a couple people asking about the
abstergo modern day stuff
uh i mean i've only encountered it yeah
i've seen one scene of it and like
i don't know it's hard to say jordan
jordan said he liked the story of it
but the characters weren't super
interesting
um but as someone who has not followed
the wider narrative
i don't know i find it very um
kind of immersion breaking i think if
you compare to old old assassin's creed
like
the original games where desmond's story
was as integral
to the plot as ezio's and altair's
especially tell you is like that
was really cool and like it was cool to
see like the parallels of those stories
but
as it got on he changed protagonists in
every game it was just like
i don't necessarily care about
yeah yeah
um mr moose says is there a difficulty
setting or is it leveled enemies
there's a difficulty setting um but
there's there's also
it's not leveled enemies like an odyssey
or um
uh origins rather different areas
require a different power level and like
as you
expand your skills and equip upgrade
your weapons and armor your power level
goes up
it's kind of like dare i say destiny in
that sense
dare i say
but it's not like leveling up in a
classic way like oh i'm level 20. this
is this quest is for level 20
recommended um but you do get experience
and when your experience maxes out you
do get
two skill points that you can use so
it's like hidden levels
i don't know it's weird um
everlast memes asks can you turn up the
gameplay
can you turn on ray tracing in the games
that have it at 1080p
on the series x it's from wayne williams
um i don't know if i can answer that not
because
yeah but embargo is just more just that
i don't like it it just seems very game
to game basis like some games may not
have
ray tracing um at least from what i
understand so like in those games you
wouldn't be able to
standby mode yeah like is the
the console i guess i guess yeah
yeah kevin's been asking about how loud
console is
um like i i mean i've got my headphones
in most of the days so i don't
i probably wouldn't hear it but like i
so far like in michael's review he said
it was whisper quiet
were his words so it's pretty cool
so jake we've been going for about 50
minutes do
how long do you think before we go to
jolly
round i think we should do it now yeah
because there's
a bit of dialogue and like more story
stuff that we'd have to get through if
we stayed here
um so why don't we skip ahead a little
over
let's see it would be an actual save
oh yeah because how long how long are
you in
how many hours have you put in yet it
looks like
16 hours yeah i'm about the same
i think 16 to 80. i don't think this is
right though
uh no this is right because i set the
quest for this
before i
um mayan 67 what's with games journals
using jars is green
drinking glasses greg miller does it too
um
that's cause i live with greg miller and
that's why
no this isn't the one all right
so it would not be an auto save there
yeah manual save one
go down to man of mystery that's 15
hours yeah
okay
or just wipe my save and we're screwed
but no this should be good no i saw i
saw 15 hours there i saw 15 hours there
you're good and we're now female 84 with
my
gold battle axe that sets enemies on
fire
wait you set enemies on fire criticals
set enemies on fire
that's pretty cool so one of the cool
things is that
so jake could you open up the skill tree
yes um so the skill tree
in valhalla is daunting it's
huge um but these are like they're more
like passives
and then you have like an occasional
like big star
i guess you want to call it like which
is an actual skill but then if you go
over to abilities
those are the things that are the really
cool things like the really cool moves
that you can use in battle
so in order to find those you have to
either turn in medals to the
uh basically the assassins brotherhood
or
you find them in these golden books that
you
can find hidden around the world and so
you get some really really cool
abilities and my favorite one is the one
to
um set poison on your blade and also
on your arrow heads which makes boss
fights
a dream i don't think i've had that one
i don't think i have that one but that
one does sound very good
that's the one you get for turning in
four medals
for the first time um
do we have any raids that i am capable
of doing
90 that one might be the club 55 here we
go
55 there we go pretty far
let's have a look i mean oh you've got
that guy as well
too that guy oh uh kendall
kendall from uh what do you call it
succession should i just
teleport there or should we like hop in
the boat and
do something have you got the cat
i don't have the cat either there is a
cat
you can get who can join your um let's
get out of here
join your crew and he just kind of hides
on your boat and goes raiding with you
um waiting for a ps5 gameplay valhalla
so
don't have the ps5 uh
kind of optimization patch just yet so
any gameplay that we've got valhalla
right now is gonna be on series
x one x and ps4 um but we will put some
up
uh hopefully when we get the patch
yeah the review is entirely serious
um if you wanna check that out and i and
i'm
i'm like 99 sure you should be able to
do 4k as well
on that um it depends if youtube
finished processing it which i imagine
it should have by now but sometimes
youtube just you know takes its time
yeah
uh mayan 67 are there random events like
in red dead redemption
2. not not in the same sense
as red dead redemption where you like
run into npcs
in the environment in in that sense but
there are world events that are marked
on the map that
have a similar vibe they're just a
little bit more scripted i would say
and then of course like you could walk
up to uh
i don't know to a animals fighting a guy
or something like that you can save the
dude and
like there's that stuff like i found a
weird little nudist colony
oh yeah you talked about that um
is that safe for stream probably not i'm
gonna say well he's he was wearing
he's wearing pants okay um so i think
it's okay let me check my footage i can
get the map location
um a lot of people asking in the chat
can you do the beowulf mission yet
uh i've already done it yeah there is a
kind of beowulf mission
it's called like beowulf but i thought
there was beowulf stuff
um it's coming as dlc
but i'm not sure maybe i'm wrong i know
i had did one
what i know that i know the one you i
know the woman with the
mold
thrown in reverse here
mystery world events okay where are you
[Music]
the weird little nudist colony
can you call up on your crewmates off
the boat like in brotherhood
no i think they'll only hop off the road
if you
raid yeah
okay i love when you go into a bridge in
this game i don't know why i think it's
just cool watching them like
lower the mast yeah as you go under
these bridges with like leaves hanging
down
and then they hopefully set it back up
again
and if you like it come on leave me
hanging crew
oh wait hit a hold a there we go
um can you get the crew to sing asks kim
um have you had a really a relationship
yes jake no i've had a dialogue
like that had a heart next to it for one
of the people in my village
and i and i like basically went on a
date with that person i did target
practice
wait that's kind of what i mean like you
mean like uh garrison
exactly pretty much that yeah
what's it like on the series x uh so far
runs great uh i've i've been doing 1440p
mostly 60 frames a second
uh sometimes i have hdr on depending on
if i'm capturing or not
uh overall looks great runs pretty well
there are bugs that i've
come across and i know you've come
across on 1x2 hopefully that's gone when
you have a chance to play
um other than that like yes
two very good questions that came
through uh just switching
to analog maneuver who was he was doing
some uh gen next quotes earlier i did
catch that that's very good
uh does switching from male to female
i've always changed the story at all
no it doesn't seem like it um because
you can change on the fly whenever you
want so i don't think it's like odyssey
and that like whichever one you don't
pick
they kind of be that might be a spoiler
huh
i won't finish that sentence but but it
seems like
it's yeah it's the same no matter who
you pick just different voice actor
uh kevin do you play skip the
relationship scene slash option
no i watch him yeah i watch
he's done the thor ragnarok oh my god i
haven't pulled you off
so i haven't found a hammer
in the in the game yet i've just been
using axes there i think there are
hammers you can use as weapons um
also damn someone in the chat managed to
find a 3080 in the wild
wow let me know your secrets
my dude please
um try lance are there any tamahawks in
the game
there are little throwing axes actually
there are there is a um
um a finishing move you can have
where you just throw axes at people in
the distance which is quite fun um
yeah some combat here uh kevin
relationship scenes please
i don't know how easily it is to get to
one yeah i mean
like i said i've been playing almost
like 15
16 hours now and i've had one dialogue
option that
hints at one but like all that happened
was we just
we just shot some arrows around and and
she was like next time we should light
our arrows on fire and avoid was like no
we can't burn down the village and that
was it
oh blair said uh they're the one who got
the 3080. it was hard
got it on the first really big best buy
drop
very lucky
i'm still running at 1080p oh no
[Music]
oh yeah that's the axle
that's one of my favorite moves that one
and there's one where you just kind of
jump is it down yeah
uh danielle tadaro hey jake and lucy i
was always a playstation player
but i'm considering playing valhalla on
the series x
in terms of performance an 8-4 and 60
frames per second
is this worth it or will the differences
be
i mean it's hard to say like lucy said
like we haven't been able to try it on
ps5 yet
um but i think it's gonna look good no
matter where you play it
oh look there's your there's your fiery
sword all right
yeah that's what i was there's some
there's some blood for you
there are some go there yeah
dismemberment is an option that you can
take
on i like cow they were like oh vikings
dismemberment
uh ethan smith uh how's the combat
compared to other creed games i guess
now that we're probably in it doing a
raid
uh jake you can tell us about that yeah
i mean
it feels very similar to assassin's
creed odyssey
and um and uh
origins i know some people on this staff
like john luke was saying
odyssey's combat more personally like i
can't
super tell the difference between the
two at least department with big changes
like the fact that
full wheeled and whatnot um that being
said like we kind of talked about
earlier but like the assassin's creed
combat has always been like
just not quite as is precise as i've
always wanted it to be there's not as
much like
hit registration as i'd like um
but like if you like the other ones
you're probably gonna like the combat in
this too
like it's it's still it's still good
like it's still fun especially some of
those abilities
yeah i think we've killed everyone nice
i don't want to use your eagle
yeah my eyes that was great blowing his
nose
i was wondering what that was uh yes the
elephant that we keep in our kitchen
no this is great um
oh these are the bits i like where you
kind of crawl on someone to help you
break down the door and get the big
treasure and stuff
uh kevin drinking games there are
drinking games
yeah oh and do some flighting maybe some
fighting would be good too yeah
yeah um here you go ken bilge says
i heard health doesn't regenerate even
after battles is that right
uh no not really i kind of like it so
instead of
health regen you have i think they're
just called rations in this game and you
get rations by picking up
uh excuse me like plants and whatnot
um and then you just press right on the
d-pad and
you get a get a health boost so you have
to be a little bit more
careful uh you can't play you can't just
like be aggressive and then run and hide
while you regenerate
see like right here is a plant that i
can pick some berries for
although i think these are adrenaline
and a rations
yeah you can um everlast you are
completely correct it was actually a
raven
um it's not an eagle i'm just so used to
seeing evil assassin's creed
but it is a little raven um
carter plays youtube do you really
recognize regions towns landmarks from
the uk
yes uh so i haven't been to
the major cities yet so i know that york
is there
jorvik was a big um
hub for viking activity in the uk
um there's a place there called the
jorvik viking center
you know like a famous museum and jorvik
is on the map
in assassin's creed but i am under
leveled and i haven't been up there yet
so i'm very excited to see what that's
like
there are some names that i like there's
letter chester shire
um leicestershire
similar to leicestershire there's places
like norwegian
um northumberland uh which is actually
where i am from
england so i'm very excited the map is
also like a small country dense and i
haven't managed to see all of it just
yet
but there are definitely places and
names i recognize but i think the
biggest thing that makes me
feel like it's definitely in england is
the way
that the npcs respond when you see them
or they spot you and they go like oh
what's all this then
yeah that's british that's what we play
it's uh has been shown a lot of love to
england
this year between this and watchdogs i
know
releasing within two weeks of each other
have you had a chance to play
uh watchdogs at all lucy i have
played a couple hours it's
i think the idea of the players anyone
system is
really cool but it doesn't give me a
thread
to follow like they're trying to make
deadsec the main character whereas i
don't
i can't really who can relate to a
hacking organization i want like the
personal touch
um so i kind of fell off it
uh quite quickly and then obviously
assessing the game
and i'm i'm really into um into abel's
story and all of the uk
all the uk slang that's been dropped in
the chat right now i really love
so we've got oily avaloy uh we've got
time i'm not gonna read it
um give me a hand with this
so after we raid we can go back to the
settlement and we can
i can see if we can upgrade anything i
don't know if i've got enough raw
materials but if i do
um we can kind of show what that's like
yeah blood warner
not my favorite we'll be playing more
since it finished the main story that's
fair i will say like it they've really
captured london
i think that's one thing obviously
assassin's creed games do very well and
so ubisoft games in general do very well
as capture the spirit of the place that
they
are set in jake did you play watch dogs
i did i played a good amount of watch
dogs legion i didn't finish it
um but i was curious about that because
i was super excited for watch dogs too
because it was in the bay area and i
spent a lot of time in the bay area
but when i actually played it i feel
like it just didn't quite nail
the bay area maybe i'm being a little
biased because they took out the section
i lived in at the time
entirely like just wholesale just took
it out
and i think that was part of it um
uh and they also didn't have bart they
didn't have public transit which i
thought was super weird
probably just because it was a pain in
the ass to make that um
in game yeah but i enjoyed
watch dogs 2 as a game but i was kind of
disappointed with the world so i was
curious what people thought of london
because it seemed pretty cool looking
yeah it is really cool looking but i
mean similar to
um to watch dogs it's that
uh you know strange little changes to
the tube for example they randomly
took away big tube stations at big
stations and then they
kind of invented some like they gave one
for trafalgar square which is very
strange
um but
yeah it can it definitely captures the
feeling of home
but a kind of uh i don't know a dream
like home where things just aren't 100
correct
yeah yeah i mean like the one thing i
remember comparing it to at the time was
like
was how gta 5 was like supposed to be
like los angeles southern california
and i felt like that was closer to
southern california
even though it was a fictional area as
opposed to
the bay area and watchdogs which was
supposed to be real it didn't quite feel
right to me
uh maybe it's because with gta i do kind
of suspend my disbelief a little bit
because like okay this
isn't actually la even though it's
supposed to be like
yeah it's fun going around in gta it's
definitely more of a
characterized version of l.a rather than
i guess ubisoft games where they try and
definitely
capture the true nature well i don't
know
should we do this event yeah yeah
[Music]
are you talking about in assassin's
creed
sorry jeremel the king you know how
anime waifus are the best
going off in the chat also are you why
are
you
attacked by a nun i don't know i just i
just talked to her i didn't even like
make a decision she was just like i hate
you
oh uh
i mean i've met somebody
young thank
i went to catholic school so this is
very familiar to me
uh everlast says can you make the combat
more
uh leave me by leave it's kind of wacky
you have to hit an enemy like 15 times
um oh my god there's none
you can poison your blade and make it
easy so jake when he gets the um
the bow and arrow up you can see like
weak points and you can kind of um
knock enemies over uh star strike you're
going to show off the create button on
the playstation 5
uh we're currently held to an embargo on
that one we will
talk about it as soon as we are able to
oh i forgot i hid my
stamina meter oh
a little bit of yeah cheese it's what
what are you kidding me what is she
vicar emilia
what the hell is this
yeah archie garcia what do you think
about the watch dogs legion assassin's
creed crossover dlc
do you want to see watch dogs crossover
in valhalla
like honestly i haven't looked into that
i'm not aware of the crossover
are you still getting absolutely done in
by this knot yeah
i need to get oh i had one more ration i
should be okay
uh you use poison oh yeah i'm good
poison by c
um
okay what you use uh use an adrenaline
power
sorry lady oh stop it stop my head stomp
on my head
should have stopped yeah always stomp
um are there any
rations or anything around on the ground
oh
almost on jesus wait
is she dead tell me again
the crows are her only friends all right
that was it
just it was just a nun
buzzfy um blair warner
yeah stomping is a move that you can
unlock
if you um you can kind of like
semi stagger people there is like some
kind of stagger meter and then you can
hit
right thumbstick and stomp on people
when they're down on the ground
and it's brutal all right where are we
headed now
should we head back to the settlement
and maybe try to upgrade it a little bit
yeah let's walk around the settlement
and see kind of the area that you're
uh living and loving
not yet not yet at some point
avor will be doing that
oh no the narrative now
in the chat is lucy show no mercy stomp
on the nun's head
[Laughter]
please don't tell father carol that i
said that
uh
i don't even know father carol's still
alive actually
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna take him
out first because i want the day time i
want i want to see the sun setting over
this
yeah and i also need a heel too so it
works out
oh this is my dog i named a mouse
okay we'll take we'll we'll take a look
at the dog in it
uh pc masterpiece uh says
so this game takes place in england not
norway
the beginning takes place in norway in a
small area of norway england's
definitely the main focus like kind of
lucy and i said before
it's kind of similar to the witcher 3 if
you played the witcher 3 and that there
was
white orchard which was more or less the
tutorial area it was small you can go
back and visit it
but everything was pretty self-contained
and then after you do that you go to
england
where you have a much bigger area to
explore
yeah they're calling for father carol
dlc
um oh so the question was uh make the
combat more
lethal um
i i don't think there's any way you can
do that however
i'm curious if maybe at some point they
might add that in dlc because they've
been doing that with ghost recon games
uh particularly the last one which had
like levels and whatnot
um but breakpoint they added like a
realistic lethal mode
and i think that could actually work for
assassin's creed
um got questions
about the dog so please can you find
mouse
and tell us all about your adoption
story with mouse the dog so there's a
mission
uh pretty early on where you help him i
don't want to spoil it because it is it
is kind of a cool mission
uh but after you get to pick a name and
there's a couple names and i i like
there's a couple options and i like
mouse because it was a big
tough dog that i wanted to name mouse
so does he come out with you i can call
him to help me
so if my i think i think that's what
this ability does
for skill sorry no ability
and i have a sign i just didn't use it i
should have used it
can you pet the dog also normally i can
i don't know why it's not letting me
though
so yeah you can i think you can pet the
other ones that are just walking around
your camp
so what is going on over here
is that a training dummy oh it's just a
dummy why are you showing up for some
reason like the ui
ah see there you go that's the like the
the next up from just a straight
assassinate
like that's uh the quicktime based event
one that deals more damage on bosses and
stuff
oh what a good boy
[Music]
all right so here is the settlement i've
built it out a bit but it's following
you
oh um i've built it out a bit but it
seems like there's still plenty more to
go and it seems like the further you get
more expands outward um
but this is i think this is where
people fish
i have something that may interest you
deliveries okay so i can get fish i
haven't
are there any multiplayer co-op or
social features
there are kind of social features so
i'll run down here actually
um so i can explain it
so you have i forget what they're called
when you build this place you own this
viking you get yolms viking or something
and you get to create basically a
warrior and then i think other people
can summon that warrior
there's a there's a bug all right oh
oh so i guess you can like customize
your raiding team and whatnot
mm-hmm
[Music]
but um so there's my yomz what is it
uh yom's viking
i'll see you later i don't know how it
works i've never actually summoned one
so sometimes i went to uh grants grants
bridge
and you can just see them standing
around
in long houses in big cities and big
settlements
you just see them and they just kind of
join your crew and then
uh when you so if if for example i made
one
and you hired them i don't know if i can
send it directly to your game but let's
just say for the purpose of this
example you hired my young viking
i can check back in in my barracks
and get some money blake would be we are
reading the comments hello
um so i can get some money so it's like
a kind of
quick and easy way you don't have to do
anything
to get uh some benefits from it you own
the giant
time here we go this is this is one i
can upgrade oh actually
yeah let me upgrade this one because
this one's
so i've got 95 so i can build this
the museum i've been collecting the
stuff for the museum
i hope it's as good as um
doubt it
so now that i've built it it opens up
like
i guess like in his case like it's
collecting roman artifacts so it kind of
opens up a little subtle story
of the empire i'm not going to talk to
him right now because
he's probably going to be super exciting
yeah
um but then there but then there's like
a bunch of different things like i don't
know what this is
alvison holgers lodge who are they
i don't know
uh joshua gilbert what you're saying is
the xbox doesn't stream any higher than
1080p
uh well i'm not streaming through the
xbox i'm streaming through
streamlabs obs right now and i didn't
set it for
1080p i set it for or i set it for 1080p
on purpose because
i didn't want to try to my upload speed
probably couldn't handle 4k
um and i don't even know if twitch
probably lets you do 4k but yeah
there are enough headaches doing this
remotely is tough as is
should we go to a city and do some
drinking and
yeah because we gotta we got a few
minutes left uh let's go do some
drinking and some flighting
i'm not sure where
so that little um anchor down
that guy yeah go there uh what capture
card are you using
it's a aver live gamer 4k
60 thing i don't know
it's it's built into my computer or not
built in but it's like inside my pc
i got it a while ago yeah i fit mine in
a few weeks ago and honestly
oh changed my life yeah having it built
in
like especially for capturing footage
not having to like put it on an sd card
in the transferring builder is
like just just being able to quickly
show you stuff and like drag it over and
drop it in slack to show people
um okay so if you want to go to the long
house
actually there is a flighting which is
like the viking rap battle stuff
[Music]
if you check the eagle
that's like um there's the drinking
so i may have already done the flighting
here because it's in this house isn't it
yeah it's the uh the hidden guy so i
i've done that one so we might have to
go somewhere else but we can do the
drinking one
see if i'm good at it for some reason
i'm pretty bad at it but
yeah no me too just like in real life
especially now not as many opportunities
to drink
the house or more
there's more opportunities to drink
there's just fewer to drink with other
people
uh edric what are your questions i'm
sorry bud there's quite a few
going on i'm trying to answer as
many as i can male female male female
ivor vo
quality they're both pretty good i kind
of like
female because she's like i don't know
she sounds gruffer and angrier and
like my viking being angry but we played
the first part of this stream after if
you want to go back and watch we played
as the mail
um brandon thanks for joining us i'll
see you next time
or bye brandon thank you
star strike does ps5 need a capture card
or you can still stream without it you
can stream without
it um
oh i wonder if it's gonna be blocked
from you know we're good now you're good
the first one's easy it's when i have to
start balancing
rodney tell me what time i can play uh
whenever it unlocks in new zealand i see
you
i think that's when or maybe it'll be 9
p.m
eastern time if you're in america
midnight in the uk
it depends where it depends on your base
hi mark
uh how easy is smart delivery
seems pretty good so far upgraded
straight away
yeah i mean if you can if it can upgrade
it just does it automatically sometimes
there'll be an update if not
you can still play it it's just
i don't think i'm gonna win
uh ethan biggest difference from current
gen um
definitely the load times sorry edrick
yeah we're trying we're trying to get
through everyone we're not perfectly
ignoring anyone
just a lot of questions um but ethan
yeah it's definitely the load times
um see you won
i did um
yeah a lot of times very very good
if i can blow on this horn over here is
it gone
oh there oh no it is here
still blow it no get drunk yeah like
the viking equivalent of drunk drunk
dialing
um so are you guys asking about the ps5
controller in the chat i
assume you are
um i can talk about the dual sense
controller but i've been i've been
playing
um assassins on the
one x so the elite series two still a
fantastic controller um
but the dual sense is a great controller
as well
it's more like the elite
series two controller than a dual shock
i would say a bit bigger in the hand
the feedback is really great very quiet
i think the battery lasts
like a very good like a long time i've
been playing
long stretches of spider-man and it's
been good um
[Music]
any word of ps5 version will utilize
features like activity cards haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers
not sure just yet but i assume that it
would
um especially as there's going to be a
ps5 optimization patch
there was another question oh so cinahl
is asking for dual wield
shield gameplay please i wonder if i
even have two shields
we can certainly try i do have two
shields all right
all right dual wield shields all right
let's go beat up some folks
um mo there are haystacks in the game
um i don't know if jake wants to go to
that
uh i'll be heading to one i'll jump off
this tower and
hop right into one hopefully i can find
someone to fight before then because
i've got some new tools stings
good jump
uh harry agent 47 what about ps5 heating
situation
i've had no issues with my ps5
overheating
[Music]
is the dual sensor game changer i mean
i would say performance matters to me
more than the controller itself
so not necessarily do you pass out if
you drink too much in this game
i don't think so i think your vision
gets super blurry
i can't i can't really do stuff like
that in games because
um i get really motion sick
so i can't really play it uh
like when i did some drinking game stuff
in this um i had to just like close my
eyes for a few seconds until
the effect had stopped
well no enemies
oh wait here we go this dude oh is he
are you gonna are you gonna flight with
him shall we
should we lock are you gonna oh it's
another drinking one
what is the battle rap mini game like uh
now us we're gonna try
and find one um it's basically just like
oh i see one on the map oh nice nice
nice yeah we'll show you in a second
where's the oh it's up there okay
okay
well
it just depends on if it's a multiplayer
game where my friends are playing
um and if it's a single player game
where it looks
best i think you might be supporting
let's jewel did it did
go big or go home
then you're speaking to fools and their
knowledge is flawed
wow not bad monger of gossip
oh my god that's really good chadwick
monger of gossip
there was a really good podcast called
gossip mongers but then the people who
ran it turned out to be a bit mean
and got rid of
the third interesting
interesting
silent whispers
a true talent
i think you just kind of walk around and
stumble
a bit drunk and then you kind of like
the fuzziness goes away
i don't think it's like witcher 2 or 3
where you have like full missions
where you're hammered and you have to
like piece together
or red dead or you just pass out
all right head up here get that
uh eagle point or whatever it's called
and then we'll see if we can fight with
these two shields
it looks so stupid a true viking
it's like it looks like a kid who's
wearing a bunch of cardboard or
something
um uh pc master race asks
what is charisma level uh so as you do
the flight things you level up your
charisma i don't think it goes super
like i think i may have just maxed it
right there with three but there's like
it's basically like a stat uh in
conversation like there'll be some
options where a character be like i
don't want to give you that but if
you've got enough charisma you can
make them give it to you i've only seen
it show up like once or twice
yeah i've seen it only show up once so
far
um but yeah if you complete the little
viking rap battles you get to
um you can do charisma
can you trade in resolution for more
frames per second or is it locked
um i think it's locked because this game
only supports 60 frames a second
and it can do 60 uh 4k
i think that's a hey haystack it is hope
so
there you go haystacks confirmed
okay let's go let's go find someone and
beat them up with our two shields yeah
maybe we'd call it a day because we've
been going for about 90 minutes
so unless this if there's something you
all want to see
on route that we can hopefully go find
uh let us know
thank you for joining asking questions
um
it's fun game you can see the full
review gamespot.com youtube.com done by
jordan remain
um and we'll have more coverage going up
over the next few days what does this
mean
uh oh not sure but east anglia
you have socks
i'm not gonna do that
come back
yeah maybe where the treasure is it's a
good idea
yeah because usually there's either
because sometimes um
i don't recall if they had this in
odyssey or not but there's uh
enemies that have really um
like good loot on them until they come
up on the map as like a treasure
huh okay
well there's the hidden blade yeah
is there a difference between how fast
the character there he is
there he is go mouse
uh is there a difference in how fast the
character is in mobility
uh feels a little more weighty i would
say
climbing wise it's kind of gone back to
whole game
to go up and b to go down
it's kind of in that place with
assassin's creed games where i think
was it syndicate which was really the
turning of the tide where you could just
climb everything
it might have been earlier than that
like remember ac the early ac's you'd
have to climb up
very specific paths and like there'd be
maybe only one or two ways to scale a
huge building
yeah it'd be more like puzzle e
yeah which i really liked and i do miss
um in this one it's more like
hold a and up and away
[Music]
double shield all right
uh mo you can choose between male f male
ivor or female eyeball
or the animus can randomly select for
you yup and you can change anytime you
want to
uh star strike asked is having two
shields give you more protection or does
one get
canceled out it seems like when i defend
a4 just puts up one but maybe like it
also protects me on the right side too
what did you
cole do how stealth in this game
uh it's about the same as the
previous two assassin's creed i would
say i like we said earlier
i think for me personally there's less
of an emphasis on stealth um
just because i want to play like a
viking but uh
here's the key you could totally do it
if you want uh
she is down there underneath okay
so
the shields do seem to do a pretty good
job of destroying enemy shields
[Music]
why the hell is that key oh wait
oh down there there we go yeah there's a
lot of cool stuff like this where you
just kind of destroy
um things and go into the little secret
tombs and whatever
boxes and
zodis you're so right vikings use
destruction not stealth and that is
very apparent in assassin's creed
valhalla for sure
all right let's see what treasure we've
got in here
i've noticed you can only get raw
materials through rating
so like i might get supplies but i'll
need
raw materials
that's useful stuff for upgrading your
weapons and armor
uh pc so a couple of quick questions
just before we go pc master is health
does not regenerate
you get rations and you tap right on the
d-pad if your health is low
um that's like food that you pick up in
the world um
so it's not a potion it's just actual
food um there is
uh tavon there is an a modern day stuff
but it's very very like minimal
um jake and i have played for about 15
hours each and we've only come across
it once um and
mayan 67 can you take drugs in this game
yes you can but we'll save the details
uh anyway i think that's about it yeah
i think that's it thank you everyone for
joining us uh keep your eyes peeled
youtube.com slash game spot games.com
we're obviously gonna have
a lot more of assassin's creed valhalla
going up uh it comes out tomorrow
we're playing on xbox series x today but
we'll have footage comparing it to the
xbox series s version too so keep your
eyes peeled for that
and thanks again see y'all